going back to our boxing guests who've
been waiting very patiently as we had
the announcement for the new leader of
the Liberal Democrats there Joe Swenson
basil Alexander and there a translator
ages gents thank you very much for your
patience that's where you talking about
your bout with Luke Campbell next month
and you're talking about how
preparations are going how are you
preparing we train hard I prepare with
the same size like Campbell the same
hire the same reach so I will be ready
on August 31st
what are his strengths and what are his
weaknesses would you say and how does
that compare with your strengths and
weaknesses he has a very big amateur
experience he has a big reach and he's
very smart boxer he has a very high IQ
so I think it will be chess match it
will be very interesting and very smart
fight Alexander you leaving up him
division you can say heavyweights if he
had the chance the option he would you
rather fight at Tyson Fury Jones a wide
world or of course I'm Anthony Joshua
ing pendulous what is can be a hotel
solution got the box here well yeah at
Rachel's gamma the New Year a boxer
which simulates a phonemic possible
Kabukicho is new tricks it has what
books you know what Joshua Walder le feu
de what them most likely welder no sorry
Walter what's it been like stepping up
from cruiserweight to to heavyweight is
that a big challenge for you and how
have you adapted to that like the the
Pattillo period yes cruiser with now
another period appearance' yeah that was
to be each cruiserweight you know
they're all alleged killer drama it's
jazzy and perky curious about the box
here act of cattle maha wisdom of
catalan ravu
I didn't really think I need to do to
make a wait right now because then I was
fighting there's a cruiser with I was
making away right now heavyweight I am
still in my own weight so I don't have
to worry about the losing the way so
it's kind of like I don't need too much
to that battle if you are successful can
some Lee Campbell what happens next
where do you go he who would you want to
challenge next I need one more belt its
IBF title now we have a future in the
future fight call me Richard call me and
Tiffany Lopez who win we can in the
future we will can unified for titles
yeah tell us about the training that
goes into being a heavyweight boxer tell
us about your regime and the challenges
that you face reproductive the terseness
now hold shift Jerusalem this in north
caprara Scotia persuade you Jim McCarthy
Trini Rocha
the attacks are a risk are also double
zero cruiserweight Rasta Mahaska Kitano
vlm
what Shawn asked a stupid white oak or
Rijo to get an ovation most feasible
shortstop excites about Amina great
Akita motivation but or a medium I I
trained exactly same as used to train as
a cruiserweight
no changes but actually we do some
changes every single training camp I
have a big huge team where we sit down
together we talk about it we make some
decisions and those changes is going to
be added to every single preparation
every single camp and that's what how
different is your trading see what
Alexander would have to be doing
traumatology of geometry said you were
the token it's it's a hard question
because we try and separate and I don't
know I don't know
he trained like a heavyweight I train
like a lightweight it's my train going
on my speed on my power my reaction for
for Alexander I think he trained more
power and I don't know how explain in
English
what's the reception how have you been
welcomed by the UK boxing fans active
mr. Chen for not the books with this
really cool approach we shed cheap low
morale is not wrong kinda very
wonderfully sometimes even very loud
yeah
what about you basil possum Perez
pneumonia the child is closed now yo th
2 News New York
dealership or AHIMA very differently
somebody is recognizing me somebody's
not recognizing me but I think we can
fix that in the future kid stuff
a gentleman really good to torchy the
very best of luck with the future with
your fight against them Lou Campbell